[MUSIC]
Welcome back.
I hope you enjoyed the previous lesson
on the common features of frameworks.
In many cases,
frameworks seem like magic.
I want to strip away
some of the magic so
that you'll better understand how your
code and framework code fit together.
In this lesson we'll be
diving into backbone and
the utility library underscore.
Backbone is a highly opinionated
framework in the NBC family.
It uses underscore for its templating,
and has its own event management and
routing systems.
We'll uncover how these features work.
I want you to follow along with
me in your own browser and
code editor this lesson.
I'll be doing the majority of my
work with the Chrome dev tools so
that I can take advantage
of break points.
It'll make it easier to open up
the frameworks internals and
get a clear idea of what's happening.
Keep in mind that the point of this
lesson is not to write backbone,
the goal is to demystify how
frameworks do things and
for you to realize that frameworks,
they're just JavaScript.
If you want to build backbone apps,
check the instructor notes for
a link to our learn backbone course.
So let's pop the hood and
see what templating has for us.